- Today we've been
celebrating all you overworked
and underappreciated mamas out there,
we love you, and I have to ask you
all the ladies in the
house seats right now,
how many times have you been
interrupted by your family
since the show has started?
(laughs)
They've all got their hands up.
Yeah, we get it.
That just proves how Rad you all are,
that you're still composing yourself.
And now I want to introduce
you to another awesome mom.
She's known for her
expert tips and tricks,
that help moms everywhere,
plan the perfect family
vacation, girlfriend getaway,
or romantic excursion.
Please welcome the travel
mom Emily Kaufman y'all.
- Heyyyy, hi Kelly its
so good to meet you.
- Nice to see you.
- Big hug.
- Well it's lovely to meet
you, but you've been able to...
Have you been able to do anything,
like travel during the pandemic?
- Well, I'm used to
traveling all over the world,
and sharing tips and pointers,
and I traveled so much this summer.
I traveled out to my backyard.
- (laughs)
I traveled around my kitchen,
I did take a couple of road trips
and tried the camping thing,
so I did get out and about,
but mostly stuck close to home.
Yeah i know this has all of us.
That was awesome i wasn't
expecting you to say your house.
Since we're stuck at home, i
invited Emily to help us plan
the perfect restful and
relaxing staycation,
all you hardworking mama's deserve.
So what's first?
- We can't take care of our kids
if we don't take care of ourselves.
As the travel mom, you
can't give anybody energy
unless you got energy in your own tank.
One of the great ways
to practice self care
is with a massage.
And right now it's difficult
to go out to a spa,
and deal with a babysitter
and getting there.
So how about we bring a massage to you.
Soothe is a wonderful
company that teams up
with licensed massage therapists,
and they'll actually come to you
and do the massage at your house.
- Y'all might want to
download that app right now,
because soothe is giving
everyone in our house seats
a $200 gift card, that I really
- (cheering)
want to get into it as well.
I want a massage.
So that's awesome.
I mean, massages I've
seen everyone in the world
got regular massages
we'd all be far happier
and we'd get along better.
'Cause it relieves our
body's take on so much.
So what's your next thing though
on the ultimate Rad Mum staycation?
- Well, after a great massage,
the last thing that you want to do is
schlep into the kitchen and cook dinner.
And moms have been cooking dinner
countless times during this pandemic.
So there's a company called DoorDash,
that connects restaurants
with the customers.
They do this in more than 4,000
cities and in all 50 States.
So how about we take that
off your responsibility list,
and have DoorDash send dinner your way.
- Guess what Rad Moms,
you're all getting a $200 gift
card for DoorDash as well.
- (cheering)
- So we're relaxed from the massage,
we are fed from DoorDash, now what you?
- There's nothing i enjoy
more than getting into nature.
I feel so connected, more spiritual,
more relaxed, more unwound.
So there's a wonderful resort,
called Red Mountain Resort
and Spa, in St. George, Utah.
It is nestled right at
the base of Snow Canyon.
It's a wellness resort.
Wellness is about body, mind, and spirit.
And we need to nurture all
those things about ourselves.
So I visited Red Mountain
and I was just thinking
that everybody else here might
want to visit Red Mountain
Resort and Spa too.
- Yeah that's where we're
sending all the Rad Moms here
in our house seats to
the Red Mountain Resort
in St. George, Utah.
- (cheering)
- It's gonna be awesome.
So tell us why you love it so much.
- We're so busy taking care
of other people all the time
that the one person we
neglect is ourselves as moms.
And when you go to Red
Mountain, it's all about you.
Whether you want to
practice yoga at sunset,
you want to listen to chimes,
the Tibetan bowls being
played in the Canyon.
Great food, great pool area,
you can take an e-bike ride,
you can have an experience with horses.
And what I love about it is
that this time right now,
to be in the great outdoors
is where we want to be.
Lots of space and a perfect way
to recharge your mom batteries.
- (cheering)
- Amen.
Well mamas tell those kiddos to just like
hush up for a second, so you can hear
the particulars of what
you're getting right now.
Okay.
It's a three day, two
night essential retreat
at Red Mountain Resort for two,
you can bring your spouse or not.
You can bring your BFF or not.
Just go by yourself if you want
and forget all those people
and be like, oh I only
got the trip for one
and lie about it it's fine.
We approve this message.
And for all you Rad Moms at home,
we don't want you to feel left out.
So we're giving away some
of the gifts you saw today
on our Instagram account.
Head to the Kelly Clarkson show,
Instagram page to learn more.